what's your advice to somebody that's in
your shoes at 22 what's the advice if I
was your little brother I was 22 years
old doing the exact same [__] as you
what is it
I mean I think you just gotta make sure
you enjoy it you know the lifestyle you
know because if you don't enjoy it and
you're doing it it just doesn't make
sense you know that's true but I mean I
think hustling is like a [__] disease
though you know
it's like I don't know I feel like I'm a
risk taker thrill seeker
rule breaker you know so to me I get I
get a kick out of that but I can see if
you don't really enjoy it or a lifestyle
then [__] man you just kicking
kicking dirt going through a bad days
just just too much you know that was
great advice I thought you're gonna say
some like education like go get your
education just you better love that [__]
oh yeah dude I mean [__] school's not
for everybody [__] no [__] that's a
gimmick you know yeah